bonsoir à toutes et à tous
je m'appelle Farid Makhlouf avec mon ami
Pascal Lazare en 2016 on a survécu 40
jours sur une île déserte
quand on est arrivé sur cette petite île
aux Fidji nous n'avions ni nourriture et
aucune assistance
notre ambition
réaliser un rêve
un retour aux sources mais aussi filmer
l'aventure pour en faire un documentaire
je me souviens de cette image quand on
commence à apercevoir l'île à bord de
notre dingui notre barque c'est une
image qui nous ravit nous rassure en
même temps
de l'eau cristalline des Bleus de toutes
les sortes
notre navigateur me tree de son prénom
coupe le moteur à une vingtaine de
mètres du rivage et nous dit welcome to
Hollow
jusqu'à la poitrine sac à dos au-dessus
de la tête
le premier pas sur le sable
nous donne l'impression qu'on est sur
notre planète
du sable blanc à perte de vue de la
roche volcanique une végétation assez
dense en première ligne des cocotiers
en revanche aucune trace de civilisation
mais comme vous pouvez l'imaginer partir
sur une île déserte à l'autre bout du
monde à 17000 km de la France
c'est pas simple
cette image c'est aventure elle commence
en septembre 2015
je tombe par hasard sur une vidéo qui
raconte l'histoire d'une personne qui a
tout quitté pour aller sur une île
déserte
à la fin de la vidéo
je viens de retrouver la mémoire ça
c'est mon rêve depuis toujours je prends
mon téléphone j'appelle mon ami Pascal
je lui dis Pascal j'ai un projet je veux
partir sur une île déserte est-ce que tu
peux vivre l'aventure avec moi et lui me
répond
magnifique ce projet on se voit quand
trouver une île une île déserte mais où
ça
on voulait une île exotique loin de tout
mais surtout loin des continents et des
hommes
alors on a commencé à faire des
recherches on disait au Japon
l'Indonésie en Polynésie un peu partout
dans le monde
bon le plus souvent on vous demande des
sommes astronomiques des milieux d'euros
ou bien vous expliquer que le site est
protégé
et c'est complètement par hasard encore
une fois que je tombe sur un
documentaire qui parle des Fidji
et là je vois cette île magnifique
dans le sud dans le Pacifique Sud au
sud-est à 300 km des Fidji
Unis de moins de 4 hectares un rocher
son nom
au lauréat et là
je sais qu'on a trouvé notre île
mais le plus simple ça serait d'aller au
Fidji pour faire du repérage mais voilà
on a pas les moyens on a même pas les
moyens de se payer en hôtel sur place
alors on va contacter on va commencer
par contacter l'ambassade est physique
qui se trouve en Belgique
par mail par téléphone et là très
rapidement ils vont nous dire bon on
peut pas vous aider
le mieux c'est de voir ça avec les
responsables des clans à qui
appartiennent ces îles désertes
ouais ok
pendant dans le même temps on avait fait
une quarantaine de demandes en
une seule personne
française touille accepte de nous
héberger et à partir de ce moment-là
alors que toujours pas pu contacter les
responsables de l'île tant pis c'est pas
grave on va bloquer une date et ça sera
le 2 août 2016
trouver des financements l'argent le
nerf de la guerre
on a vu on a chiffré le périple aux
alentours de 20000 euros ce qui
représente billet d'avion bus bateau la
logistique en général mais il nous faut
aussi du matériel numérique pour filmer
l'aventure
caméscope caméra miniature
batterie panneaux solaires carte SD
alors on commence par contacter des
futurs partenaires des sponsors sur le
plan
national et international
bonsoir la santé qu'on a contacté
100% de réponse négative
de français quinquagénaires que personne
ne connaît qui vous demande de l'argent
ou du matériel pour aller à l'autre bout
du monde sur une île déserte
c'est pas facile
on a quand même réussi à récolter
récolter la somme de 4000 euros
principalement versé par des commerces
locaux qui ne connaissaient bien les
amis et la famille
à cette somme on a rajouté 3000 euros
chacun nos économies
et nous voilà au final avec un budget
divisé par deux 10000 euros
se préparer
se préparer physiquement c'est pas
essentiel une aventure comme celle-là
c'est je dirais que 80% de l'aventure
c'est du mental
en revanche on doit apprendre à mieux
nous connaître dans la douleur on a
dormi dehors dans les Alpes à moins de
10 degrés on a pratiqué l'escalade
descendu une rivière pendant 3 jours
bivouac et pêché de toute façon tu
pêches pas tu manges pas
on fait aussi beaucoup de
sorties nocturnes avec des sacs à dos
lourds de 25 kg le but c'est de souffrir
ensemble
mais en revanche là où c'est très
important c'est hyper hyper important
même vital
savoir pêcher savoir chasser et avoir
des notions en survie
parce qu'elle vous dirait entre ce que
l'on croise savoir faire et ce que l'on
sait faire entre les deux
il y a la mort
dis-moi où passer nous sommes le 2 ou
2016 date de nos départs premier vol
Marseille Amsterdam 1h45 arrivé à
Amsterdam 4 heures d'escale deuxième vol
Amsterdam c'est où l'encor du Sud 10h30
de vol arriver en Corée du Sud 18h
d'escale bon le temps pour nous de
trouver un hôtel type un truc pas cher
du tout pour essayer de dormir un peu
parce que jusque là avec le décalage
horaire impossible de fermer l'oeil
troisième vol Corée du Sud lundi au
Fidji 10h30 de vol encore une fois
évidemment tous les vols sont classés
excité inquiet
et très fatigué
on a pas le temps d'y penser on prend un
bus 5 heures de trajet destination
suivant à la capitale
arrive à la suivante on prend un taxi
pour nous rendre chez notre hôte on fait
quand même un petit crochet dans un shop
pour acheter le traditionnel cava de
bienvenue
le cava c'est une racine une fois pilée
diluée avec de l'eau devient une boisson
à la fois relaxante et euphorisante
mais le cava c'est surtout une coutume
sacrée chez les vidéos vous pouvez pas
vous rendre chez quelqu'un ou bien
encore moins sur une île sans apporter
du CABA
la première nuit chez notre hôte on se
lève à l'aube on prend le premier bus en
partance pour ce centre
on sait même pas où aller on sait pas
pourquoi commencer on a devant nous une
page blanche
alors évidemment quand on rentre en fin
de journée
on est à la fois déçu mais très inquiet
parce que le temps aussi je joue contre
nous notre projet lui il est de 40 jours
sur l'île déserte mais notre tour il est
prévu pour le 4 octobre
le soir après le repas pendant qu'on
boit du cava avec notre hôte on lui
explique nos difficultés
et là le regard regarde français et nous
dit
mais mes parents ils travaillent au
gouvernement
le karma
le lendemain elle les appelle
et c'est pas un lui explique on doit se
rendre là-haut princial comme style
comprenez la mairie des provinces
la mairie des provinces gère la région
de Layou elle a eu si un territoire
grand comme la France dans le Pacifique
Sud dans lequel se trouve 38 île habité
donc 38 villages
dans cette région protégée les touristes
et les pêcheurs autre que les habitants
n'ont pas accès
elle obtient un rendez-vous pour le
lendemain on est reçu par deux personnes
dont un responsable
et là on expose notre notre projet et
puis très rapidement nous dit
je prendrai contact avec le clan des
como à qui appartient l'île désert de
Lorient
et je reviens vers vous
un espoir est né
cinq jours après on demande à le
recevoir et là je me souviens de
son visage fermé j'ai eu un moment de
stress et j'étais blanc j'arrive plus à
bouger et nous regardait il nous dit
j'accepte à une condition alors là on
est en appelé on attend
je veux un papier Signé de l'ambassade
française de responsable de l'ambassade
française qui approuve votre périple
en fait on apprendra plus tard
que les responsables fidèles craignaient
de devoir endosser la responsabilité de
nos décès
ouais
en fait j'avoue que le moment on a eu un
gros doute c'est quand on
regarde le responsable fusion puis on
lui dit on ira on va aller sur Lille
sans eau
là il nous regarde comme ça il te fixe
et il te fait
après 72 heures de navigation très
compliqué en fond de cale dans un bateau
de ravitaillement
on monte à bord d'un dingui on traverse
la barrette corail et là direction l'île
de comment là on est accueilli par deux
personnes super chaleureuses
on offre encore une fois vers le Cavard
on est conduit dans la mutation du chef
du village et à côté de lui assis à même
le sol un chaman qui va bénir il va
bénir les racines de kava
d'autres personnes arrivent ce genre à
eux et là en fait le but c'est qu'il
discute entre eux pour décider si on
peut rester sur l'île des como et
évidemment se rendre sur l'île de
laurier
ils acceptent
et là
on est soulagé
et on peut enfin boire le Caval
traditionnel cava avec toutes ces belles
personnes
bon la nuit a été courte le soleil est
déjà levé nous on est de nouveau dans
une dingui cette fois direction l'île
déserte de lauréat une heure environ de
navigation
on a la chance d'être sur le Pacifique
et de contempler un spectacle
extraordinaire
des baleines qui jaillissent de l'eau
et puis ce truc que j'avais jamais vu
un poisson de poisson volant qui nous
suivent
juste à 4 cm de l'embarcation
c'est bizarre mais avec Pascal on a
l'impression que tout ce beau monde est
là pour nous souhaiter la bienvenue
au
nos premières heures sur hollow Rua
deux enfants dans un magasin de jouets
on a Lucile c'est un truc de fou ça fait
un an qu'on y rêve et puis on est là
quoi
mais bon on va vite redescendre et très
rapidement faut trouver de l'eau
parce que les champs de survie
sans eau surtout avec cette humidité
cette chaleur dans trois jours maximum
et par chance
il avait plus la semaine d'avant ce qui
va nous permettre de trouver une petite
flaque d'eau un peu plus loin dans la
bouche
le soir bah tout simplement on va dormir
sur le sable au bord de l'océan et on
découvrira plus tard
qu'il vaut mieux ne pas dormir à même le
sol à l'intérieur des terres la nuit tu
as l'impression que le seul bouge
tellement il y a d'activité c'est les
insectes c'est les crabes les
bernard-l'hermite c'est les araignées
serpents
le deuxième jour et là donc le deuxième
jour il est consacré à trouver le spot
l'endroit on va bâtir notre abri alors
proche de l'océan à l'intérieur des
terres mais surtout jamais sous un
cocotier c'est prendre une coco sur la
tête c'est fatal
et au final
d'après huit jours de lutte
on a enfin fini de bâtir notre refuge
la deuxième semaine
une semaine est là en fait on s'adapte
on fait comme les Fidji on pêche sans
canne avec uniquement du fil de pêche un
hameçon
et comme à part on va utiliser une
vieille technique fidèle qui consiste à
faire sortir le bain à l'ami de sa
coquille en leonnant à proximité comme
ça et un sifflant régulièrement
et il commence à sortir ses pattes
doucement puis sa tête et puis là il
faut l'attraper rapidement et voilà elle
n'a pas pour la pêche
on fait aussi le tour de l'île à marée
basse tous les jours avec noir peau
artisanaux bah pour trouver coquillages
crabes poisson murène ce qui est
comestible
mais en revanche ce qui nous inquiète
beaucoup c'est l'eau mais il est
toujours pas tombé une goutte de pluie
il nous reste encore quelques cocos qui
sont pas encore très hauts au risque de
se briser une jambe
pendant cette semaine là on a perdu
aussi beaucoup de poids on est on est
affaibli mais chaque effort devient
vraiment vraiment très difficile
la troisième semaine poinçonner et une
fois encore pas une goutte de pluie on
doit se rassurer on doit éviter
s'exposer trop longtemps au soleil la
Fnac qu'on avait trouvé et maintenant
assez chier
alors on va creuser sur une soixantaine
de centimètres au même endroit
et on va trouver de l'eau boueuse qu'on
va devoir filtrer avec les moyens du
bord
des bouteilles en plastique que les
vents et marais nous ont ramenés
servions de récipient
alors la première bouteille on coupe le
bar on la retourne le premier filtre
sera mon tissu comme on peut le voir en
fait c'est un morceau de mon bermuda qui
a la fin de l'aventure c'est un short
ensuite de moitié du sable et pour finir
des granulés de coquillage et là vous
avez un
un filtre certes de fortune mais qui
fonctionne très bien
ces derniers temps
la pêche a été très peu favorable nous
arrive de ne pas manger pendant
plusieurs jours trois quatre jours
d'affilée
et depuis qu'on explore l'île on a
trouvé aucun tubercule
il y a pas de manioc il y a pas de
patate douce il y a pas de tarot
je me souviens un soir parce qu'elle me
dit je crois que j'ai trouvé un moyen de
piéger le crabe de cocotier
le crabe de cocotier c'est un animal
nocturne adulte il peut mesurer jusqu'à
un mètre de diamètre
avec une pince il peut soulever jusqu'à
25 kg
il se nourrit principalement de la coco
de la coprah du fruit de la coco
il prend la cocotte il arrive elle a
débourrer
et avec sa pince il casse la
cocotionner les doigts sans problème
et notre piège à base de fil de pêche
attaché à un morceau corail dans un
récipient au fil d'alarme
et comme à part évidemment de la copra
attachée à l'autre extrémité de ce même
fil plusieurs mètres plus loin
d'ailleurs
et là
la nuit suivante on découvre notre prise
un crabe de cocotier celui-là il faisait
à peu près 3 kilos facile
et on va enfin pouvoir reprendre des
forces
la quatrième semaine
la pluie
la pluie bénie du ciel
et même si la plus qu'une heure on a le
temps de faire des récoltes et surtout
faire des récoltes d'eau claire et de
l'eau potable et ce jour-là ce jour-là
c'est un beau jour
depuis cette quatrième semaine beaucoup
de choses ont changé
c'est vrai on est plus des étrangers
pour Lille
on fait maintenant partie intégrante du
biotope
on comprend les vents les marées
on est plus habile au lancer de harpon
on sait où trouver les bons appâts pour
la pêche
on prend même le temps de contempler les
couchers de soleil de
d'admirer le paysage depuis le sommet de
l'île
la nuit quand tu observes le ciel la
Voie Lactée
tu as l'impression que tu peux toucher
les étoiles
il y a pas de pollution luminaire il y a
pas de pollution de l'air il y a pas de
puissance sonore
c'est comme le commencement d'un nouveau
monde
on possède rien et pourtant on est
heureux et en paix
malgré la soif la fin nos pertes de
poids moins 14 - 16 kg des dents cassées
des dents cassées des piqûres de
moustiques les piqûres d'araignée les
morsures de murènes et serpents les
intoxications les malaises mais malgré
tout ça la cinquième semaine
on a un gros pincement au cœur il nous
reste plus qu'une semaine
on arrive maintenant au bout de cette
belle aventure humaine on va devoir
quitter
celle qui nous a accueilli rendu plus
humble
celle qui nous a nourri et protégé
celles qui a réalisé nos rêves
celle qui nous a fait découvrir que
c'est parce qu'on a rien qu'on est
comblé
d'ailleurs ça me rappelle un proverbe
qui dit ou un dicton peut-être la vie
est souffrance et la cause de cette
souffrance et le désir
le retour à la maison
on est complètement détaché de ce monde
moderne revenir à la réalité à la vie
normale
c'est très compliqué nos pensées notre
esprit il est toujours là-bas sur l'île
il y aura en revanche une chose à
changer et oui
il est important pour moi de passer du
temps avec ma famille
des choses simples passer du temps avec
ma maman
passion en voyage avec ma compagne
partager des moments avec mon fils
là-bas tu peux te blesser gravement ou
mourir personne viendra t'aider quand tu
es sur une île déserte retiré du monde
tu prends conscience que la vie elle est
fragile
le temps le temps n'existait plus au
contraire de ce qu'on peut vivre ici ici
tout à coup tout allait trop vite pour
nous les gens ils parlaient trop puis le
bruit
je sais pas comment vous l'expliquer
mais là-bas on parlait plus on écoutait
tu écoutes l'océan tu écoutes la faune
la flore tu écoutes tu écoutes Lille
cette expérience nous a reconnecté avec
les éléments qui nous entourent en fait
on avait oublié qu'on était vraiment
à travers la technologie on se coupe de
plus en plus avec notre environnement et
les autres mais quand tu es sur une île
déserte entouré par l'immensité du
Pacifique
tu te sens infiniment petit
mais
tu ressens un sentiment d'équilibre
parfois
mais parfois il faut vivre le pire pour
se redécouvrir merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]